[Musica]
strega
quel fuoco untore
nel Medioevo bastava il pettegolezzo per
essere messi alla gogna
esattamente come oggi
sicuramente i mezzi sono cambiati gli
insulti pure ma una cosa Rimane costante
e risuona come un tamburo che accompagna
la storia
le fake news bastano a manipolarci la
coscienza
sentitevi diversi migliori superiori
alla mia dichiarazione
Noi siamo diversi non siamo come i
nostri genitori non siamo come i boomer
siamo diversi
Cosa significa
significa che noi non abbiamo bisogno di
aiuto per utilizzare i nostri cellulari
non usiamo Facebook e Sappiamo benissimo
come informarci
che ci vuole Vai su Google in 3 secondi
ti trova milioni di risultati a posto
basta così no
Eppure anche negli anni 90 i figli erano
meglio dei genitori
e negli anni 80 e 70 e via via fino
all'inizio dei tempi
Se c'è una cosa su cui dovremmo essere
d'accordo è che il contesto storico fa
la differenza
cioè
ad oggi giorno non sapremmo come fare
cose semplici senza l'utilizzo della
tecnologia
cose scolastiche come ricerca di
geografia
versione di latino
Anche semplicemente contattare persone a
noi care che sono lontane sono cose che
non sapremmo come fare altrimenti la
tecnologia ce l'avete più semplice
come noi zanzed non riusciamo a capire
le generazioni prima della nostra
millennials genix loro non capiscono noi
e quelle prima di loro
e un giorno verremo considerati anche
noi obsoleti o vecchi perché siamo una
civiltà in continuo movimento in
continua evoluzione la storia si scrive
mentre noi parliamo
è un pezzo di questa storia è stato
scritto per esempio dei Partigiani
proprio durante la gita scolastica mi
Insomma ero in visita in questo museo
partigiano mi sono ritrovata in questa
stanza piena di incisioni erano veri e
propri testamenti e la più popolare era
Viva l'Italia
sapevano di stare per morire e in un
certo senso per via di un paese a cui
loro erano fieri di appartenere
e qui mi sono chiesto
come è possibile che persone
perseguitate dal proprio Paese fossero
tanto patriottiche
i Partigiani erano patriottici amavano
questo paese un paese nel pieno di una
dittatura nel mezzo di una guerra
mondiale che stava devastando le sue
città e i suoi cittadini
considerando il contesto storico ai
nostri occhi con la mentalità di oggi è
impossibile amare ed essere devoto in un
paese con queste caratteristiche
ed è anche vero che noi adesso viviamo
in un contesto storico migliore rispetto
all'Italia dei Partigiani
Eppure nonostante questo lo spirito
patriottico è praticamente nullo Nelle
generazioni più giovani
perché noi giovani non abbiamo il
patriottismo nel sangue
Innanzitutto cos'è il patriottismo
dal ciclopedia Treccani
il patriottismo è un sentimento di amore
devozione e obbedienza nei confronti
della patria
sono un po' lontano come concetto Ma in
parole povere è un modo di appartenenza
E insomma l'essere umano è comunque un
animale e Certo in alcune cose hai
voluto ma mantiene certi istinti
primordiali come l'esigenza di
sopravvivenza che ci spinge a cercare di
restare vivi e ci mantiene i sensi
allerta in situazioni pericolose e il
branco che appunto quel moto di
appartenenza ha un gruppo di persone con
elementi simili come appunto il contesto
storico
scusate
[Musica]
E come mai questo sentimento è più è
meno presente nelle persone che
differenza c'è tra me e i miei genitori
che differenza c'è tra i giovani e le
generazioni che li hanno preceduti
la tecnologia
meglio ancora il metaverso
Cioè non esistevano cose come Instagram
Tik Tok Twitter WhatsApp non esisteva il
concetto di
realtà virtuale
in questa realtà virtuale
è necessario conoscere la storia
Cioè ormai la storia è acqua passata che
me ne faccio io di nomi e date inutili
Non è che ci ho preso un caffè con
Giulio Cesare e non seguire Leopardi su
Tik Tok chi se ne frega
e poi
insomma
e poi ormai abbiamo tutte le
informazioni a portata di mano dobbiamo
anche leggerle dobbiamo anche farci
un'opinione di quello che leggiamo
e come possiamo cambiare se la mia
opinione fosse diversa da quella del mio
gruppo devo dare più retta al mio senso
di informazione come individuo o il mio
gruppo di appartenenza
Personalmente io preferisco dare più
importanza
al mio senso di informazione come
individuo Perché so di poterlo
verificare perché quello che dico è una
mia responsabilità
a me fa imbestialire quando dicono che
noi giovani siamo una massa di pecore
che segue quello che fanno gli altri una
massa che segue la moda nel momento mi
fai investire semplicemente perché non è
vero non esiste una generazione di
persone che condivide all'unisono le
stesse ideologie un esempio Galileo
Galilei
Non condivideva per niente come dire
sistema solare eliocentrico quindi è il
sole che gira attorno alla Terra l'hanno
costretto ad avviare è morto ma non lo
condivideva era persone nate con lui
e si può cambiare iniziando a farsi
un'opinione delle cose e a questo che
serve la storia necessaria e conoscere
la storia perché storia Magistra vitae
la storia di insegnante nella vita
perché con le sue conseguenze che stiamo
vivendo in questo momento
si può imparare Si può cambiare
e poi se c'è una cosa che ci differenzia
veramente noi giovani da chi è venuto
prima
è proprio il contesto storico perché noi
siamo Dove siamo perché gli eventi
storici sono susseguiti come sappiamo
e possiamo differenziarci da chi è
venuto prima
proprio imparando nella storia
e non solo dando importanza alle fonti
che la documentano
perché le fonti sono un filtro
attraverso il quale possiamo decidere
cosa tenere
quindi il fatto per quanto più oggettivo
possa essere E cosa tralasciare cose
magari date dall'autore della Fonte che
magari non è rilevante o attendibile
un esempio dovete vedervi con degli
amici chiedete un amico Dov'è Marco
e quello vi risponde Marco è caduto
dalle scale perché era distratto
ora il vostro amico in questo caso la
fonte storica
e la fonte di Porta Marco è caduto dalle
scale perché perché era distratto
Ma Marco quando è caduto non c'era
nessuno con lui non c'era il vostro
amico non c'eravate neanche voi
il pezzo di perché era distratto l'ha
aggiunto al vostro amico
e la differenza tra fonte e fatto è che
il fatto è che Marco è caduto la fonte
riporta anche altro
è come se a 300 anni utilizzassero Tik
Tok come fonte storica
ora dovranno comunque
darci un'occhiata a stare starci attenti
prima di darla per vera perché Certo il
contenuto del video è deciso dall'autore
se l'autore decide di avere ragione che
quello che sta dando
per scontato È oggettivo è vero non è
detto che sia così
l'avete fatto Caligola in storia
quello del senatore cavallo per chi non
l'ha fatto Scusate lo spoiler
allora perché lo riteniamo un pazzo
perché chi lo racconta ad esempio
Svetonio
lo riteneva antipatico Ora aspetto ogni
ora era simpatizzante per il Senato
molti siti usavano per il Senato
traffici e diciamo che ora se tra il
100% anni nel Tik Tok
come dire c'è qualcuno che lo contrasta
ne abbiamo la prova un altro tic toc per
esempio ma all'epoca Chi è che sapeva
scrivere chi raccontava se chi racconta
ti trova antipatico
non è
Anzi è più che logico che maniponerà la
fonte che arriverà ai posteri e parlerà
male di te
è per questo che è importante verificare
la fonte per iniziare a stabilire cosa è
soggettivo e cosa invece è importante
È così che ci si fa un'opinione delle
cose ed è da qui che si parte per fare
qualcosa di diverso per cambiare le cose
Ma quindi
le fake news bastano a manipolare la
nostra coscienza
sì
finché non torneremo a noi stessi come
individui
sì
finché basterà una sola voce a formare
un coro
sì
fino a quando non saremo esseri umani
come esseri pensanti
Grazie
[Applauso]